[Music]
one year in office two unsuccessful
impeachment proceedings more than 50
ministers dismissed and pedro castillo's
presidency is yet at its worst hour he's
facing five corruption-related probes
the president denies any wrongdoing
close allies and family members are also
under investigation
i have sworn by god to serve my country
even if my family is insulted every day
and the majesty of the presidency is
offended i submit myself to justice to
clear the crimes that i'm accused of
with respect to due process
my duty is always to tell the truth
political foes interrupted his speech
some left the chamber castillo admitted
making mistakes in these past 12 months
but said his achievements have been
ignored
president castillo preferred to focus
his speech on health the economy and
social programs nothing about the
growing discontent of the majority of
peruvians who demand his resignation
[Music]
opinion polls say 71 of peruvians
disapprove of his government and for
critics there's no hope that his
presidency can be rebuilt
we want castillo to understand that his
cycle is over he started his government
with an anti-corruption banner however
there are already five fiscal
investigations that clearly demonstrate
that he is committed to corruption the
52 year old rural teacher who was sworn
in with his farmer's hat won the hearts
of many who believe castillo is honest
we know that he's a good person and that
he'll never steal
during his second year castillo said he
will offer his hand to work for the good
of the people but to achieve that he
needs allies in a country rocked by
political instability
castillo was expelled from his own party
opponents in congress will try to unseat
him again for many who put their trust
in him his offers to work together may
just be too late mariana sanchez al
jazeera lima peru